[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le but c'est qu'on ne boive ensemble
alors c'est un boulot oui mais
on veut trouver des trucs et ça va bien
[Rires]
pourquoi dit on que voisin gastambide
mon ami a la grosse tête
pourquoi dit on que fondation hmida la
grosse tête
parce qu'il refuse de faire des scènes
fille avec les gens dans la rue
[Rires]
on monte je fais encore trois fautes par
mots j'ai toujours du mal avec les
langues étrangères je n'ai jamais pu
apprendre les tables de multiplication
je ne peux pas réciter l'alphabet d'un
seul coup si ces difficultés ont
toujours été pour lui un complexe avec
le succès de nombreux psychologues l'ont
contacté pour lui expliquer qu'il était
en fait très probablement hpi comprenait
un surdoué comme quoi malgré ses
difficultés franck gastambide prouve
bien que le talent et la passion mène à
tout
nous a dit ben lui qui en bas on venait
on va lui parler baïocco là il faut
porter s'écoule justement est allé voir
besson et me dire ben voilà on vient de
faire un film qui s'appelle pattaya qui
a bien marché et on est des enfants de
taxi on les a tous vus c'est mon premier
souvenir de deux sorties ciné en bande
de potes et on rêverait de faire ça et
luc nous a dit ok si vous racontez moi
et le public wallon du luc à un
monologue dali je suis le pitch on va le
découvrir un petit peu là alors
évidemment c'est qu'un teaser bien s'il
a une minute ou pas cligner des yeux
sinon on va pas y avoir grand chose
énorme c'est vraiment les premières
images de taiwan ont dévoilé dans tpm
pinsard est repris par d'abord on est
super fiers de les amener ici pour
vérifier aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
prochain il
[Applaudissements]
ya des micros et tu as well as oui oui
et non j'aime je t'ai pas devoir regarde
non mais pas mais non ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est
ce que le succès du raid monter la tête
eh bien pas du tout car s'il ya bien un
mec simple c'est franck par contre voilà
ce qui s'est passé juste avant ces
images aussi accablantes
c'est le mec de devenir il m'a répondu
comme épargne domique comme state à
l'école
[Musique]
on a pris un comédien en fait l'afrique
qui va se passer
[Musique]
je coupais des photos d'enfance montré
des photos de france inter
ou
[Musique]
est ce qu'on connaissait sept personnes
enlevées sûr que non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]